hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and this one's title might
look a little bit familiar to you guys
so i've been subscribed for a little
while but recently i actually did a
video on downloading uh your own
or anyone actually anyone's youtube
videos in the mp4 format and uh this was
done actually using a piece of
javascript i put together uh that i got
from one of google's blogs or forums and
they basically uh you put it you copy
and paste it into the address bar and it
would download any youtube video in its
highest quality in the mp4 format well
now i have a bit of an announcement that
youtube has come out with a new feature
sorry about that background noise anyway
youtube has come out with a new feature
which allows you to download your own
youtube videos in an mp4 format uh
basically if they just built this in uh
youtube's been having a lot of server
troubles recently uh but they've been
actually making quite a few updates to
their page if you didn't already notice
so in order to get to this feature all
you got to do is hover over your name
and go to my videos and it'll load
youtube.com my underscore videos when
you're signed in
and you can go to any video you've
uploaded already and underneath it you
will see a download mp4 button before
these were the only buttons that were
available you can play the video which
will obviously take you to the url you
can edit the video which is basically
the description of the video the title
the uh the tags and anything else of
that nature the annotations button was
the whole annotations editor and i was
considering doing a uh you know an
overview or a tutorial on that but we'll
see how that goes uh the audio swap
button which is basically adding other
uh other audio to it basically
music vendors who have decided to let
youtube and google
overlay their music on your video so you
could use that
insight which gives you you know
information about that video and i think
i will be doing an insight overview and
i'm just giving you guys you know
everything that's about
youtube insight you can promote the
video by hitting that button you can
delete the video from youtube after a
confirmation window and now uh the new
addition underneath the saw is the
download mp4 button and what it does is
if you just click it you'll see at the
top it inserts that quick little piece
of javascript there i don't know if you
saw it and then it'll come out with this
uh your uh your actual mpeg4 or mp4
movie you can hit the open button and it
will actually
save the title of the video as well as
all the description and everything like
that and when you hit open it'll open
the video in quicktime player just like
you uh would with the the javascript
downloaded video so it's opening right
now and here it is
it is not in the highest possible
quality which is the only downside
if we show this video in full size which
would be
normal size i guess
but if you show it in the full size it's
not the 1280 by 720 that i would have
expected youtube uh to give your video
in so
it will be a bit pixelated which is the
only downside but um you are getting uh
the best uh
basically that's the quickest way so you
are sacrificing a bit of quality when
you do it that way you're not going to
get the hd out of it but you will get
everything else you'll get the audio
it'll be crisp and clear and everything
of that nature so here's the video here
it was the tech channel of the week
uh so i'm just going to delete that from
where i just uh downloaded it but
basically uh it is the easiest way
because it saves the title and
description of the video and you'll be
able to find it anywhere on your
computer just by using the windows vista
search box and just typing in the title
of the video you downloaded
but uh when you use the javascript way
which i showed you earlier i'll try to
include an annotation for you guys
you won't have the title and description
of the video when you download it but
you will have it in the highest possible
quality to back up on your hard drive so
there you go guys that's the second of
the ways that i'm i'm pretty much aware
of right now uh for you guys to download
and back up your own mp4 youtube videos
onto say an external hard drive or
backing it up onto
some service where you can back up a
certain amount of gigs of videos or
files or so that's basically it for you
guys thanks for watching this hd
tutorial stay tuned for more if you have
any other tutorial ideas or requests you
can feel free to subscribe and message
me and i may consider doing a tutorial
video for you guys or a request video
for anyone who feels that they have a
good enough question so thanks for
watching this one and have a nice day
peace